[Music]
and lost in translation news submitted
by Peter Morgan Japan is still
struggling with its English sides in
preparation for the 2020 Olympics oh yes
can we see some is it like those lost in
translation or like those really [ __ ]
up well I only have two examples oh my
god what does it say this is [ __ ] but
it's just supposed to be the exercise ok
so here's like your mom's [ __ ] shirt
so not applied by the wall what does
that mean I don't know
this other one is don't go oh no we're
[Applause]
done the goddess yep so there was this
two-month investigation investigation by
the Japan tourism agency I'll tell you
one thing Japanese and English does not
go back and forth very well on Google
Translate that's exactly what's
happening because they're using Google
to have a permanent [ __ ] so you guys
want to translate the samurais spirit
the same thing I know does my best
friend at the time was Korean I thought
you guys like a middle ground what's the
Billikens like neither was like what
takes that average of Chinese and Korean
and then the average of Japanese the
same tactic yes cuz back in the samurai
days hiragana was only reserved for
women and children and then no no yeah
there is I don't country its kanji yeah
but there's there's one letter that's
now what they do is they combine all the
words together yeah but in like feudal
times the royalty and samurai wrote in
kanji which is Chinese letters anyway
yes it would have just been Chinese oh
wow I love that it was you and your
Korean friend like Chinese and Korean
and then you pick the culture that both
of you are supposed to hate
don't get tattoos when you're 19 guys
Joe's like we win again okay so another
example they found is that one transport
company refers to children as Dwarfs
cute wharves the kind of art yeah and
then another one includes instructions
quote what happens to the children fare
from what age wait what does it mean but
these are like the really poorly
translated wait but don't they have like
a lot of like foreign exchange like so
you know ones have like a lot of
teachers right they're like the jet
program yeah that's all the answers
today people so they have tried to
contact the tours or like whoever's in
charge because a lot of these companies
are private companies and they're just
translating it themselves so people will
approach them saying like hey you know
it would read better if it was this way
not only in English but in French too
because there was this your doing French
oh yeah because of the Olympics oh yeah
you know the whole world can be good so
um but yeah I wanna hear this - France
is barely gonna be there I don't know
what they don't get me started on Canada
who traditionally sucks at the Olympics
Canada depends on whether it's the
Summer Olympics or the winter in the
winter so then people that know how to
translate they're telling these
companies like hey you know can we help
you and they'll be like okay so how do
you how are you supposed to write it so
then they'll write it out for them
correctly and then these companies will
still end up using the Google translated
right
oh no so like this one example about the
French French language they this man who
has lived in Japan for 15 years and he
also runs a French language school in
Yokohama he he went to this museum
that's dedicated to telling the story of
Japanese nationals were abducted by
North Korean agents and in the French
translation it says that the Japanese
should be
sent back to North Korea oh my god so
what's happening here the reason why the
reason why these Japanese people are
using those bad translations because
they are saying Japanese people can read
that it makes perfect sense for Japanese
people when using they're thinking that
Japanese people are gonna be reading the
English translations which makes no
sense because there's Japanese right
under that so they're writing it and
like like jab glitch pretty much no no
no it's like it's translated but it only
makes sense for Japanese speaker oh I
think I understand so you're looking at
the sentence structure if you took
English words but then you applied like
Japanese grammar to it because Japan is
a post particle language which means
that the sentence structure is different
like a subject comes before or like
sorry after you sound a really smart in
the end but two seconds and then I lost
it it's almost like completely opposite
subject comes first another Jesus
another bad one is the sign at the
former president in Hakone that says
what you put off your guilty shoes and
come into prison politely don't
did you just keep that's exactly what
they say [ __ ] that songs about
they're never gonna dance yeah take off
those guilty shoes yeah that makes it
seem so welcoming like hey you're in
prison now come hang out yeah come into
prison politely do you guys remember
those station areas like those like
Keroppi and all that [ __ ] and it they
always had some morning glory you know
it was all [ __ ] up like this dude
Bart's mom the other day we went to go I
thought we were doing but then she has
gone out of the house I know but I don't
want to say that God so well I don't
know what we're doing
it doesn't matter that's not the point
Sarris what she's wearing then she had
this jacket on right it was sunny outs
and she takes off the jacket and it says
dead inside it was like a bright pink
shirt instead she's glowing like big
wide cuz she's happy as [ __ ] why did she
get that [ __ ] as you asked her why she
tried fixing it cuz I think somebody
told her what it was what is it saying
well it's a dead inside and then so what
she did was she blacked out the first
part of the D to make it a tell so now
it means Li like lead-in solids right so
not in her mind she's I'm a leader she
could also be led inside like I am made
of the same way I mean by that in Asia
I'm sure I'm pretty sure that's nothing
yeah let me she didn't read it first or
what does she think it said she probably
thought the judges she could read
English phonetically I don't know if
super duper mine she was like I could
fix this ah but it was like dead inside
and it's all huge bold [ __ ] moves
there's a whole site dedicated to this
it's called like it's like Engrish calm
or some [ __ ] like that
oh yeah and it's all the [ __ ] up
straight A's and t-shirts yeah I love
those especially when it's like an
innocent-looking old lady would like the
most Rocchi of [ __ ] like I sucked yeah I
[ __ ] I tore some [ __ ] yeah should make
that you do apparel you should make that
I know dude
might've duck-duck-goose baby coming
20:25 there you go it's gotta be Asian
style though so it's gotta be like a
cartoon like it's got to be like the
happy like happy and bright pink and
then just like some crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah
you feel about the Asian tattoos though
that people get out here it's all like
it's all [ __ ] up and it's just some
[ __ ] up it's like Bart's not back
it's not that it's not that bad compared
to this some of the [ __ ] I see people
here yeah he told me he'll point he'll
point um I'll be like his says little
sister on his shoulder like what
we're like didn't ariana grande also get
one make sure that like little girl no
it's it's it translates to like small
tiny grills oh yeah girl that's the
brand of grill though yeah people don't
know they just I didn't just go to the
tattoo shop for me to pick whatever they
think it's cool there's a guy our all
24-hour and he was he's one of those
guys that like walks around I mean muggy
and everything because he's like always
amped up but then like he just has a
little sister and like all these like
random like two Asian words all over his
body
I don't think you knew what they meant
oh you didn't ask me oh I don't want to
ask him
Oh cuz you don't want to get be like
it's a survivor nobody looking opera he
just was misled by his tattoo artists
like me I know I never understood oh
yeah tattoo utterson Google Translate
actually I [ __ ] up because I I lived
in a city where there's a ton of Asian
tattoo artists we all do it to North
Carolina and I got it from my random
white hat about the tattoos and letters
for the fast so you a Chinese man with
your career best
and Japanese tattoo in North Carolina
that's America right random white guy
awesome peacemaker that was oddly
inclusive and in some way it was
probably like are you sure got bad cheek
he's probably for I guess the mine sex
remember when we were Australia and
we've really wanted a tattoo that like
that like remembered or like that
reminded us of us being there together
I'm so glad we to get it though cuz it
was a bunch of shady ass tattoo artists
that day it was like a holiday so all
the best ones were like on break and all
of their apprentices were like hanging
out and then everyone sucked yeah yeah
we looked at like three different shots
like five miles I think what were you
gonna get the rule or something
something Australian okay good horse
an Australian horse go to cotton I was
gonna get a noodle question I don't know
how much time you have okay have any of
you guys been tattooed anywhere like has
anybody put a tattoo of you on their
body
yeah kidding films cuz I just got one on
my 30th birthday someone sent one to me
I am on somebody's died your face my
face full colour it feels interesting
this is like flattering terrifying but
you know the reasoning for it
um I think just like being a you know
being a fan actually know this person I
mean I don't want to out them but I
think they had they had been through
some things in the past and it was to
cover up scars oh well I think that
that's really empowering a barbarian and
they picked my face which headshot was
it this one yeah it was it was actually
smoldering one it was like me like I
know Gina has yeah someone used Gina's
face as I cammer mate or something how
would you have felt except if that
tattoo though was bogged up there like
this is you but it's like your face I
think of you yeah a little bit
I do they're like I drew it myself yeah
yeah damn why did you do that
[Music]